التطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا وبالتحديد من
باخموت في الشرق حيث تظهر المؤشرات ان
المدينه على شفا السقوط رغم نفي اوكراني
لروايه الروس
وفي هذه الاثناء اشار مراسل العربيه الى
ان القوات الروسيه تحاصر بخمد بالكامل
لكنها تواجه صعوبه في المحور الغربي فيما
تتمسك القوات الاوكرانيه بمواقعها وترفض
الانسحاب وقد اعلنت هيئه الاركان في الجيش
الاوكراني التصدي لاكثر من مئه وثلاثين
هجوما روسيا على مدار ال24 ساعه الماضيه
في اتجاهات كوبيانسك ولمانسك وبقيه محاور
دونتس وقد قال الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات
الروسيه لا تتوقف عن محاولاتها لحصار
باخموت بينما تظهر الوحدات الاوكرانيه
مقاومه شرسه وقد اتهمت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه باستخدام
المدنيين في خرسون دروعا بشريه بعد نشر
مضادات جويه بين المباني السكنيه
الروايه الاوكرانيه حول الوضع في الشرق
تعززها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التي اكدت
استمرار الضربات الجويه ونيران المدفعيه
في استهداف مواقع الجيش الاوكراني في
دونتس واشارت الوزاره في بيانها الى اسقاط
اثنتي عشره طائره مسيره اوكرانيه واعتراض
سته صواريخ خلال العمليه
واضافت ان قواتها استهدفت مقر قياده كتيبه
ازوف فيزا باروج ودمرت مخزن اسلحه اوكراني
في المقام
وبينما تشتد المواجهات قال جنود اوكرانيون
على خط التماس بدونيتس انهم يتمسكون
بمواقعهم ويكبدون القوات الروسيه خسائر
باستخدام المعدات الغربيه مثل قذائف
الهاون الفرنسيه في الصنع
الان اصبح الامر اسهل بكثير من قبل قد
تحولت قواتهم الرئيسيه الى باخموت لكن في
بعض الاحيان يحاول العدو الاعتداء على
مواقعنا في مجموعات صغيره بالمدفعيه عده
مرات نحن نعرف اهدافنا مجموعات المشاه
وقاذفات القنابل الاليه وقذائف الهاون
طائراتنا مسيره تكشفها ونستخدم الاحداثيات
للتصويب واطلاق النار
الان حيث مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر يتابع
الاوضاع عن كتب رائد اهلا وسهلا بك اخر
المعلومات الوارده عن معركه بخموت وهل
تحولت بخمت الى ازوف ستال جديده رائد ام
لا يمكن قول ذلك
نهارك طيب طالب بالفعل ربما تعتبر باخموت
هي الاعنف رغم ان المعارك تدور في جميع
المحاور ان كانت الشماليه او الجنوبيه
الجنوبيه
الشماليه الغربيه افديف كمارينكا اوغلادار
كل هذه محاور فيها معارك عنيفه وبالفعل
يعني مستعره لدرجه كبيره حتى ان محور
كوبيانس كوليمان سباطه عاده القوات
الروسيه لتتقدم في هذا المحور وبالامس
كانت تبعد ثلاثه كيلومترات عن كوبيانسك
اليوم هي تقاتل من اجل اقتحام كوبيان
القوات الروسيه بالفعل تصلها تعزيزات
وامدادات عسكريه كبيره ان كانت بشريه وان
كانت بالاليات طالب باخمه حتى يعني لا
يسرقنا الوقت بالفعل الجيش الروسي او قوات
فاجنر طوقت المدينه من جميع النواحي
تقريبا الا المنطقه الغربيه ما زالت
مستعصيه حتى الان لكن منذ بس عده ساعات
فقط معلومه نريدها منك يعني في في لقط انه
جرى اخراج جميع المدنيين من باخموت هل هذا
الكلام صحيح ام لا ما زال هنالك مدنيون
هذه المعلومه بالذات لا بد من الاشاره الى
ان المدنيين تقريبا غير موجودين على الارض
منذ فتره فقط يعني المقاتلين هم من يكونون
الا من كانوا في بعض الملاجئ اليوم انا
يعني استمعت لاحد
المتحدثين من الجنود
الروس الذين يقاتلون في باخ متقال بان
يعني الاتهامات التي يواجهها الجيش
الاوكراني بان يعني روسيا تستخدم
المواطنين كدروع بشريه قال بان هذا هو
العكس بالضبط يختبئون في المنازل وعندما
نقتحم البنايه او المنزل يخرجون لنا
المدنيين كوجه
لايقافنا عن القتال او الضربات او يعني
القصف بالفعل هناك لغط كبير في هذا جانب
لكن الجانب الروسي اول مقاتلين وبشكل شخصي
يعني انا استمعت منهم يقولون بانهم يصدرون
المواطنين للمواجهه قبل ان يعني يواجهوا
الجيش الروسي الفعل المحور الغربي طالب لا
بد من التعريف المتلقي هنا اسمح لطالب
هناك معلومات عن انسحاب تدريجي من مدينه
خروما وهذه المدينه هي او البلده في
المحور الغربي التي تقدم اليها الجيش
الروسي قوات فاغنر من ناحيه الشماليه نحو
الغرب وهي الطريق الوحيد القريب على طريق
شاسوفيار بلده كراسنا هناك انسحاب تدريجي
على شكل مجموعات صغيره من الجيش الاوكراني
الى الطريق السريع للذهاب الى
القدر لكن هناك انسحاب تدريجه ساكتفي بهذا
القدر منذ نصف فرنسا العربيه رائد الاخضر
شكرا جزيلا لك رائد على كل هذه المتابعه